die ausbreitung ist nicht mehr zu
verhindern eine pandemie ist
unaufhaltsam so äußern sich virologen
und epidemiologen in diesen tagen das
corona virus hat nämlich eine fatale
eigenschaft zwar scheint sich das virus
doch nicht ohne symptome zu verbreiten
in vielen fällen ist der
krankheitsverlauf aber so milde dass die
infizierten ihn kaum bemerken und so die
infektion unbemerkt verbreiten das macht
die ausbreitung nahezu unkontrollierbar
aus china gibt es derweil gute
nachrichten aber auch verstörende bilder
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das virus
sucht sich seinen weg außerhalb von
china hat es kreuzfahrtschiffe mit
unverhältnismäßig hohen zahlen an
infizierten regelrecht verseucht und
jetzt sind fünf briten in einem
französischen skigebiet am montblanc
erkrankt und auf mallorca ist ein
dritter positiv getestet worden und die
zahlen steigen und steigen weltweit
verdachtsfälle werden schon gar nicht
mehr gemeldet und es sind inzwischen
schon mehr als 37.000 menschen mit dem
neuartigen corona virus infiziert und
zwar positiv getestet darauf und ob
selbst diese zahl eben stimmt weiß
niemand die meldung erfolgen nämlich
laut den kenntnissen des virologen
gérard krause komplett durcheinander es
sei nicht bekannt wann die menschen
erkrankt sein wann die diagnose war und
wie der krankheitsverlauf war
unverzichtbare informationen zur
einschätzung der epidemie
das chinesische gesundheitssystem
scheint mit diesem fall zahlen komplett
überfordert zu sein und der verdacht
signal dass auch andere staaten
überfordert sind und zwar die wo
verblüffend wenig fälle gemeldet werden
in einer neuen studie zur korrelation
zwischen fallzahlen und dem flugverkehr
von und nach wo anfallen zwei länder mit
unerwartet wenigen fällen heraus
statistisch müsste es in thailand zum
stichtag der untersuchung mindestens 35
fälle gegeben haben
es sind aber nur 25 und in indonesien
würden zwei bis drei fälle erwartet
werden es gibt aber keinen und das auch
noch vier tage nach der veröffentlichung
der studie die forscher dann schließen
nicht aus dass zahlreiche infizierte
hier nicht gefunden wurden und sich das
virus jetzt unbemerkt verbreitet was
weltweite folgen haben würde und genau
das ist ja auch die befürchtung der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
insbesondere
afrika haben sie dabei im visier hier
wurde bisher noch kein einziger verdacht
zwei bestätigt allerdings ist das auf
diesem riesigen kontinent etwas seltsam
insbesondere weil dort intensiv handel
mit china getrieben wird die wer möchte
jetzt schnell mit ihren expertinnen und
experten nach china und dort die
ausbreitung genauer untersuchen denn nur
dann werden wir erfahren wie gefährlich
die krankheit wirklich ist ob die
sterblichkeit weiter bei zwei prozent
liegt oder darunter oder darüber dass es
zurzeit bei diesen zahlreichen
unsicherheiten noch absolut unklar
doch china lässt die whu im moment nicht
ins land das es absolut fatale
vielleicht weil die regierung nicht
möchte dass die bio diese bilder zu
sehen bekommt hier liegen opfer des
virus in leichensäcken in zimmern und
auf fluren es ist verwunderlich und
besorgniserregend dass die wwe raw nicht
ihre arbeit aufnehmen kann die lage
bleibt also sehr unklar
seit geraumer zeit werden auch keine
zahlen von verdachtsfällen mehr
veröffentlicht so dass es nicht
auszuschließen ist dass die
veröffentlichten zahlen der bestätigten
fälle ausschließlich von den kapazitäten
in china und nicht von den tatsächlichen
fall zahlen her führen denn trifft es zu
dass es deutlich mehr infizierte gibt
würde das auch bedeuten dass die
krankheit weitaus weniger tödlich wäre
als bisher vermutet und das wäre eine
gute nachricht denn eine verbreitung
scheint kaum noch aufzuhalten zu sein
der britische solchen experte jeremy
fahrer sieht in einem interview mit dem
spiegel jedenfalls schwarz seiner
ansicht nach wird ein impfstoff zu spät
kommt und sich das corona virus weiter
ausbreiten er geht davon aus dass das
virus wie die krippe bleibt und nicht
mehr verschwindet oder aufgehalten
werden kann seine hoffnung ist dass die
ausbreitung des virus durch die
drastischen maßnahmen china erstmal
verlangsamt wird und sich zum beispiel
hier in europa nicht in der
erkältungszeit ausbreitet denn eine
entwicklung wie in china würde selbst
das gut funktionierende
gesundheitssystem hier in deutschland an
seinen grenzen bringen und da gibt es
inzwischen gute nachrichten in der
region um werden kaum noch neue
erkrankungen gemeldet also sprich die
drastischen maßnahmen zeigen dort
wirkung doch und das befürchtet die vero
da das virus sich schon weltweit
ausgebreitet hat ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass es in einem
anderen land nicht so gut eingedämmt
werden kann und es gibt ein problem mit
dem so niemand gerechnet hat die
schutzkleidung wird knapp und sie wird
fast ausschließlich in china hergestellt
und eine neue studie hat herausgefunden
dass der erreger bis zu neun tage lang
an oberflächen überlebt und ansteckend
bleibt das sind alles keine guten
nachrichten
noch sind wir hier in deutschland kaum
gefährdet wie es scheint tatsächlich
alle infizierten gefunden zu haben
und das wird in zukunft vielleicht nicht
so bleiben und darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen hier geht es zu unserer
playlist zum thema mit noch einigen
wirklich verblüffende infos und wer die
videos vor allen anderen bekommen möchte
das geht am besten über die kanal
mitgliedschaft unterstützt und damit
auch noch und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran